when i start to to investigate
this area
uh it came to my mind that it's going to
to to change the world from my point of
view
this is only
a question of time
and not a long time three four five
years till we see all the financial
market
move
into the blockchain
and to the
digital assets
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community vc fund in silicon valley in
partnership with lomitek and sponsored
by homeward ventures hippo insurance
opposed hillel at stanford leap and
birthright excel
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders today i will be speaking about
cryptocurrencies with scheidatika
founder and president of ins
mr tatika is the founder and president
of inx a fully regulated digital asset
trading platform for listing and trading
cryptocurrencies security tokens and
their derivatives inx was the first
company in history to file an f1
prospectus with the sec for a registered
security token ipo
mr tatika has over 25 years of capital
markets experience trading and building
networks and technology play in the
banking and financial industries
welcome to 20 minute leaders how are you
good thank you thank you very for having
me here
thank you very very much for being here
i'm looking forward to talking with you
about
you know both your journey as an
investor and company executive but also
today as part of inx and looking at
cryptocurrencies trading platforms and
and where we are in this world and so
shy
what i'd love really love to do is i'd
love to take you back a little bit and
learn more about you before we dig into
cryptocurrency and
give me a little bit of a round down as
to who you are and sort of what what are
the things that you did you if you look
back on your journey you're really most
most excited about
i'm coming from
25 30 using the
financial traditional financial market i
used to be a trader in bank eponym in
israel mid 90s
i established my first company trading
between uh online trading on fx in
between banks and the clients
on
98 or 99
um
during uh 2001 i established uh another
company trading uh between banks only uh
intel dealer broker
trading uh
uh effects and
interest rate uh derivatives between
banks
on 2007 i established another company
um offering a b2c
derivatives trading uh all companies
under license either in eu eu u.s so
israel and during this time i'm
like a very active angel investing with
a
portfolio of 15 to 20 uh startup
companies spa mainly in the fintech area
in shooting a little bit
and i'm uh director a member of the
investment committee on the audit
committee with al chula shahan pension
fund and provident fund uh
managing
more than 60 billion dollars
incredible and so obviously there's a
big pattern here of fintech and trading
tell me a little bit about your
perspective on fintech what is it about
trading and what is it about the
financial services that really that
really captured your interests
i think the
my vision on uh 2017 by the way i sold
in a trade adoption on bitcoin strike 50
back 2014 or something like this but uh
um the idea of ionics and trading crypto
came to my mind on 2017 when i saw this
hype of the icos
on one side
companies people managed to raise
uh
billions of dollars with a white paper
of a few pages
saying something like give me the money
it will be okay and on the other side i
saw the ages the asking of the the
written clients
and
you know early adopters and people like
this and things like that
and when i start to to investigate this
area
uh it came to my mind that it's going to
to to change the world from my point of
view
this is only
a question of time
and not a long time three four five
years till we see all the financial
market
move
into the blockchain
and to the digital assets i'm not
talking about bitcoin i'm not talking
about ionics token i'm not talking about
uh digital currencies i'm talking about
the technology the way of keep the
information of trading of transfer
information or a currency or financial
instruments from one
side to another side from one
individual to another from one bank to
another so for my point of view and this
is what i said on 2017
um we will see dollar dollar digital we
will see euro digital uh we will see
shekel digital and you know we saw the
in the past six months the cbdc uh
reports and
we see all the
major central banks are moving towards
the digital world uh because there are
huge advantages over years over here you
know uh um
you have full transparency who holds
when
uh 24 7
privacy
under laws or regulation
the regulator can have an access
to the information who holds what wallet
and when which currency where in any
seconds and who is moving what
there is only a question for them
there is only
the question is time when we will see
the
the the shares that we are familiar with
today like apple and google are moving
to the blockchain it will be the same
apple show but on blockchain
um tokenization of assets and of course
security token and for me
since it's going to be a trillion dollar
market it's not a billion-dollar market
it cannot work without the regulations
100 relation not a little bit uh if you
if we want uh uh if i
want
that my mother and my daughter uh uh to
be part of this game only with 100
secure and transparency and confidence
and this you achieve only with
regulation so this is why we choose
ninex to go on one side fully regulated
platform for currencies security tokens
derivatives whatsoever
on the other side going with um
with the uh
finding a prospectus to the sec
for issuing
uh first ever security token approved
registered with the sec
surprisingly we succeeded
so before we get dive deeper into in x
you said a few things that i think are
really interesting that i'd like to to
dwell on for just a little bit
this idea this this notion what you also
started talking about in 2017 and before
that and the the idea of digital assets
and moving to digital and you get a few
examples there you know we we see this
in the news all the time and and you
know we're seeing different
high-profile individuals claiming to
fame and different different buzzwords
like like ethereum and and bitcoin etc
what are the implications
if you are correct what are the
implications on the world on society of
moving to digital assets
um look
uh i'll i'll tell you like this first of
all
when you when you trade everything on
the blockchain and again let's try to
imagine
that
you don't need the bank or the bank is
something over there but you never go to
the bank
and now you want to transfer money from
here to philippines to vietnam to us or
to europe 24 7 you just click the bottom
and it moves
100 secure
leave all the of cyber and the
hacking you can solve this this is
technology so right
the banks don't need
all the back offices
uh a huge number of employees
um if you ask my son uh
i have uh four kids and the you off you
ask if you ask one of them uh go to the
bank to sign or something you will look
at me and say
what are you talking about why should
they go to the bank to sign i have a
smartphone i can sign here
so
for them this is more
um more
um
for them
and this is where the the world goes you
know you're going now to to to pay in
the apple store or whatsoever and you
pay with tap on something and you don't
need cash and the future of the world is
no cash no cash at all there's no need
for cash
so
um
if if i want to trade now apple share i
have i can trade only five days a week
from nine o'clock to
four p.m that's right
why why can't i trade can i trade 24 7.
you know right 20 years ago when i
wanted to buy a
switcher i needed to go to the mall and
today i can buy 24 7 on the internet it
will be the same everything right 24 7
from a mobile phone
this is the one that we are going to
so so shy you're bringing with you
dozens of years of of financial
understandings in in deep financial
instruments like like banks and then
you're an investor in multiple
startups in the fintech space
you're now you know a thought leader in
the cryptocurrency space
what is inx and what are you actually
trying to do with the organization
what we are trying to to do with inx is
on one side
to
enable
to everyone
following the regulation the laws
above 18
doesn't matter but
enable to everyone
the
this
beautiful platforms
of
and accessibility to everyone to trade
all different type of financial
instruments
and to
write the book
of regulation
together with the regulators
you know when we first met in the spock
with the sec before we uh filed the
first draft of the prospectus on
early 2018 january february 2018 we had
a meeting with them
where
they looked at us and say
okay we understand what you want to do
but there are no rules
no procedures
we don't know
but if you are willing
to
try and
write a book together with us
uh we will help we are not promising to
approve we are not promising anything
but the door is open and this is what we
try to do with inex
to
to make and to bring
this technology and this digital assets
world and this new vision of how the
financial world
will look like
to put it under the umbrella of the
regulation
okay
now
how does this fit into you know the
current stance of of cryptocurrencies
and and where we're headed with
where is this in in the middle of the
whole chain
uh if you can repeat the question
because i
i lost you for a second
so and where where is this in in the
chain of where we're at with
cryptocurrencies so how is this actually
going to then
impact where the world is moving in
terms of crypto
um
the train has already left the
first station
uh
and um
you know we saw uh uh paypal and we saw
facebook and we saw uh visa and uh
mastercard
uh talking about uh moving into
blockchain and moving and accept bitcoin
as a payment
i believe they are not working and they
are not doing anything in a vacuum of
regulation
besides facebook which
is a little bit different but i believe
that paypal and this worker the
mastercard and visa and apple uh all of
them before they did something before
they came out with
announcements it was with coordination
with the regulators
so for me when apple or paypal or
payoneer
uh speaking about accepting
bitcoin or accepting digital assets this
is with the coordination with regulators
when we see that the fed
and the ecb are talking about uh going
with
um
small
uh trials here and there with a euro or
a dollar coin digital dollar
this is the part of the process and the
process eventually i believe three four
five years we will move only to digital
currencies
right and so
now as you're working with startups and
as you're thinking more critically about
the space
where where are the gaps so what what
what is now what how is the world
transforming now where young
entrepreneurs can come and think through
them i think the gaps
is
uh
mainly
um
the ability to adapt
new technology
by the mass market
and um
you know if we try to look back
um
early 2000s
when we had the nokia with the bottoms
and now we didn't have this the
smartphones and
steve jobs came with the iphone i
remember i read article where they said
maybe market share of five percent ten
percent
fifteen percent
a few years after that you don't see any
anything besides besides smartphones
even my mother
she is 80 something almost 90 smartphone
so um
the gaps is the the ability
by um by the mass market to adopt this
new uh technology so i think the one of
the mission of companies like us is to
enable
uh the accessibility and to simplify
uh the access to everybody to this world
because
there's no need to go to the bank no
need to have a
physical wallet with cash inside
uh
these are the this is the main gap i see
of course technology
you know
uh processing of uh
10 or 100 or 1 million or 10 million
process a trades per second technology
we will solve this it will take another
month
technology we know how to solve
now do you see yourself staying in the
fintech space
you know if you know it also in the
long-term future is this really a place
where you see yourself evolving you're
continuing to evolve and continue to be
a part of of the different revolutions
that are going to take place
can you repeat the question i i i of
course
do you see yourself staying in the
financial services market in the fintech
space whatever it may look like you know
throughout the throughout the next even
let's say if you've already been there
for for two three dozen years for the
next two three dozen years is this still
a place that is
that is intriguing enough for you to
continue
to continue in the same path that you're
going
the same
path that you're going
i don't know i enjoy
i wake up in you know i walk like 20
hours a day and i i enjoy what i'm doing
so
yes as long as i have fun you know i
could have i could have uh
retired
many years ago and
and i decided to
to to change the the world and to do
something um
to do something which
is going to be
going to effect
on each and every one of
us and
this is why i i decided to go through
this path you know when i started the
inx
it was more or less the same time that
binance started i could have started
something like like with like binance
and to have a crypto trading platform no
regulation whatsoever not to touch in us
and probably i would have printed a
machine of money in my salon instead of
carpents but
i decided to go with with
the
regulatory path which i believe
is is the only way
to build a sustainable a company for the
next 50 years
i love it and i love the idea the of
building the sustainable company for the
next 50 years yeah i think that's i
think it's remarkable and and shy i
really want to thank you for coming i
have a few more questions about your own
journey rather than kryptos or inx and i
want to take you back to your childhood
you know before you were a bank trader
what really fascinated you as a kid what
what really sparked your curiosity
this is a good one
uh
i
i grew up in a boarding school
uh
for six years from age 12 to 18
and
i think i've always said i will do my
first 1 million before age of 30.
and
this is what i did
i love it and what is what what inspires
you today whether it's in your work in
your personal life what serves as an
inspiration
again what is
what inspires you today what serves as
an inspiration
um
beside my kids
to have a vision of something
and to find that
you are right
you know when i started this journey for
four years ago and i spoke about
regulation transparency anonymously on
trading uh people in the community
looked at us and say what the are
you crazy because we are talking about
decentralization
no
central banks anonymousy
and for me
the technology is good the idea is good
but anonymously doesn't work
and today we see uh more and more people
uh in the industry and outside of the
industry talking about transparency no
anonymously and things like that and
this is inspire me because you know to
think about something and to have a
vision
before everyone else
and then
the market follows you
this inspire me
very very cool
and and what are and what are three
words that you would use to describe
yourself
uh
speedy
the execution
and
close to people
so on one side i i do
multitasking multi-task missions on the
same time very fast
execution ability
i think
this
one of my expertise
but on the same time to be very close to
to uh
the people and you know in from
employees clients investors friends
family
very very cool
thank you very very much this is great
best of luck with that thank you thank
you for the positive impact and stay
safe and stay healthy
thank you so much youtube thank you
you